good morning believe nation today's
message is be unafraid over to you
Pharrell Williams how many times have
you guys you know NSU in a situation of
need a moment of need yo you know what I
need I need a job right and you blow it
off and in three years later there's a
guy you know on an infomercial
describing exactly your idea and he's
showing you how great your product works
you have to be unafraid to listen and
unafraid to think there's something that
you have is a good idea so this is an
important message because I can't tell
you how many people writing on the
channel and leave comments and say I had
this big idea I had that idea that that
guys now is making millions of dollars
off of the differences that guy or that
girl took action and you didn't what a
lot of us do is we make lists right I
know a lot of entrepreneurs like to make
lists you make a list of all your ideas
right one day I'm going to do this you
make this list and it's a B and if you
never actually take action on it then
you're never going to see momentum
you're never going to see results and so
instead of just making to-do lists all
the time and list of ideas actually take
momentum on it and the easiest thing
that you can do the thing that will lead
to results for you is the minute that
you have an idea to do something take
some fall small form of immediate action
whether that's emailing somebody with us
doing research whether that's calling up
somebody whether that's book in a
meeting with somebody whatever it is
take some immediate form of action
because that's going to lead you down
the path that momentum and lead you down
the path of success and and give you the
best chance of actually turning that
idea you have into something that can
make you a lot of money and ultimately
achieve your goals so stop just writing
ideas down stop just making to-do lists
stop just adding adding adding adding
start taking some action and if you do
that you'll be that guy on TV instead of
watching them
believe so my question that they say is
why are you afraid of your ideas why
aren't you following through what's
holding you back why are you not taking
immediate action once you come up with a
new idea for your business I'm really
curious to find out leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you guys for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events beso